it's a beginning of the next corridor
cut cast buddy
how's everybody doing welcome back once
again who are we here with today do you
guys want to go round robin and
introduce yourselves yeah that's good
Jake okay well hey my name is Jake
Watson I'm the producer of Courville and
welcome to our podcast favorite pizza
favorite pizza probably sausage
pepperoni two meats yeah yeah I mean why
you know maybe add a little bell pepper
in there if you're feeling I mean you're
already eating pizza what's the point
crust maybe but I know I'll just take
normal hand tossed pepperoni sausage
let's go you know what I ordered a pizza
from a pizza place lately and they
delivered it to my door and it was so
heavy and I'm holding this pizza I'm
like this pizza waste like legitimately
like 10 or 15 pounds maybe probably can
pounce it was a word about Shenzhen on
this did you get a meat why I opened it
up and because the thing is like I was
like I want a thick pizza please and I
opened it up and the pizza crust was
like two inches thick on the end and two
inches wide on the outer diameter unser
cumference you got that deep that extra
deep dish and I don't know if they just
slapped two pies together or something
like that but it was an incredible pizza
experience it was like I couldn't tell
if I was eating focaccia bread or I'm
never gonna order from anywhere else
ever again
Wow who are you introduction hi my name
is Sam I've already told you about my
favorite pizza but so there's not much
else to say I'm a co-founder of quarter
digital and a frequent guest of this
podcast so thanks thanks thanks for
having me your bonus well I'm Christian
and business manager core digital and I
also take these podcasts so here we are
nice hey Christian welcome thank you
appreciate it
thanks from Tex
pepper and a pizza and meet Jesus
pepperoni and you know if I have to go
more put some meat on that thing is the
meat Jesus all the all the meats oh well
the meat Jesus at point out least it's
like yeah it's like all the meats they
got they got bacon on it bacon pepperoni
Jesus will take anyone into his kingdom
just like any meat on that pizza Wow I
think it's the person eating it is the
one who needs the forgiveness hi my name
is Nico I'm a production assistant at
corridor when people need coffee I'm the
one who goes and gets it and my favorite
pizza is there's this one pizza shop
that's a lower Manhattan they have to
our slices of just cheap-ass pepperoni
but the crust is coated with corn flakes
corn flake drums before they put in the
oven and is the best pizza crust ever
had that's my glaze oh yeah that one's
five minutes yeah that is the best
yeah just like hey it isn't we're not
doing anything with these you're the
last customer you want this yeah chicken
I just want to ask you are you sure that
you're using the microphone on your desk
and not the one in your webcam Jake's
voice get upgraded here guys I don't
know what to say oh my god I knew Jake
turn up the volume that's for the
speaker mmm
is this good yeah you sound good
yeah guys wow there's a yeah we've made
some we've made some mistakes here I'd
like to be the first to apologize but
you are the truest of the true tones
when you're watching the corridor cast
and you get to see us at our best and
our worst
so welcome ale yeah speaking of us at
our best Jake tell me about that Jersey
that you're wearing do you like it we've
been working on these for for a long
time now this is a true majestic that's
a majestic brand MLB brand baseball
jersey I'm working on these with Jay we
got the katakana corridor right hmm
we've got our little well it's are
actually our unofficial baseball team
name is top well papa Sam and the and
the and the grounders or no why papa fly
high grass look Jake I know you're a
balm in 70s like funk band but also a
baseball team Jake I know you're a ball
man so give me your opinion are you are
you a long bat kind of man for the the
Grand Slams or a short short bat kind of
guy for the bunts ah man that's tough
you know I've been watching baseball for
years and all in my whole life I've only
ever seen like four or five Grand Slams
like you drive while I was watching you
go out there and swing for the fences uh
yeah yeah I mean you know like I like a
good bunt just as much as the next man
but you know it's it's not as exciting
as a Grand Slam obviously you think the
boys had what it takes this year
oh yeah a bunt is like the most anime
baseball move though you pose before the
ball yeah like listen for the ball and
it just like bounces off your bat
there's also a lot of like interior
monologue ins for a bunch cuz it's not
something you just do like willy-nilly
you have to plan it out so you're their
thing like if I bunt this ball he'll be
forced to run forwards therefore getting
second guy the second baseman on to the
third base which sells for a score yeah
at all Happy's you know as the balls in
there well the ball is traveling towards
you and you don't think about any of
that entail you're in bunt formation
right like the ball is like two or three
feet away before you even figure out
what kind of strike you're gonna give it
right yeah so yeah what about you Sam
what's your favorite kind of baseball
hit hit I'm one of those excel bats I
want one of those like 4 or 5 inch a fat
bat my fat bat kind of boy yeah no I
love just gave it a little smack through
and send it flying out of the park no
I'm a slow runner so that big bat gives
me a little bit more air on the ball you
use pine tar on my feet actually I use
it because once again I'm not I'm a slow
guy I'm not much for skating I don't
have enough you know I want as much grip
as possible as I'm running the first
base huh never made it there you know I
got a few games this weekend coming up
ok good luck good luck Sam swing a leg
[Laughter]
how is your house you're unreal
rendering going I heard you guys did
some recording the other day because I
can sit around in pixel [ __ ] all day if
I want to but like until I have an
actual like scripts let's perform it's
not actual like stuff to start building
from like it's all basically our indie
so to speak so yesterday we held a
remote voice-over session basically
where Niko Clinton myself hopped on
discord we're all recording high-quality
files locally and our individual
locations we've read through a script
improv and
phenoms and clips and today i started
going through and I'm basically editing
like an audio-only version of the video
so that way it will help me create a
blueprint of what to animate it is a
true animation in that sense in that
sense that your your scripting and your
recording the audio prior to the videos
exactly so then basically the way the
next steps work is once it's edited not
perfectly edited like we'll do more
editing after we render out all the
footage but basically I'm just setting
up like alright here's an audio track
that I can build out animations and
camera work from as if this was what was
actually happening on step so I have my
audio there and then I will pair that up
with facial animation next where
basically I'll use a phone - basically
mime what each person is saying and
attach that animation to their
characters face and then the next step
after that is doing body animation and
since we're not using motion capture
suits basically I have a whole library
of like seated expressions and talking
and laughing and crying and scream you
know like all sorts of stuff which then
I will like pair to each moment so that
way they're like emotionally consistent
how come you didn't use a mocap suit
it's it's kind of like a space thing
right now because like I could use like
the xn suit I could just put it on and
sit here in my desk
but like I don't know it's it's there's
not a lot of space to move around right
now where I'm working and yeah I figured
that I should just I can just use a lot
of like canned animations for the body
in the expressions and do some manually
Manuel tweaking to them to make them fit
did you because if you look at the
effects artists react it's like the only
thing other than like going wow or
whatever blah blah is simply just
turning to the person next to you and
speaking like that's the only like
specific thing that happens other than
like the whoa oh my god
so but but that's why we did this video
specifically it's because it's like all
right it's dialogue and face based and
it's people on a couch so it's like a
easy point of entry to making like a
fully animated piece like this so this
is really just the tests for all of you
watching this is just the test that
we're gonna do before we attempt to
actually record an entire VFX artist
react episode and post it with this
method without anyone knowing if it's
live action or not we're just gonna oh
man we're just gonna float it out of the
challenge well they just today an artist
just released a real-time merely photo
real model of our Superman boy and if
you know possible boy uh which your boy
what's his name again and yeah yeah yeah
someone an artist made like it just was
went online today and it is crazy how
good it looks for a real-time model I
mean it's it's comparable to like any
model to be totally honest like any
photo real rendering but it's all
operating and able to be captured in
real time so the only difference the
reason I'm not doing that right now is
because that takes months of research
and work and just like a crazy amount of
skill that I haven't built up yet but
but to be totally honest yeah like down
the line here like well you know it's a
funny possibility
I'm joking about it but when we went
when we met in that snoop that one time
he was serious about it he was like man
I'm just trying to figure out how I can
find somebody that that can give me some
renders so so I can be on stage
entertaining but I'm not actually there
you know because at once it's like
that's that was his thing that was his
invest the next level thing that he's
trying to get at I mean he was on stage
with Tupac for the hologram so you just
like do that for me for my shows and
then I could be somewhere else yeah you
reference the gorillas as inspiration
for all that it's like they got to
figure it out they can do a concert
anywhere yeah like no one knows what
they look like so anybody come it could
be any musician
one guy though right basically clean was
grills is a band that are lay up like
when they're on the stage like all the
lights are dark and I'm just playing and
you don't know what they look like they
only show like they're animated that's
cool like characters so yeah no one
knows what the grill is actually look
like it's funny cuz it's like I I
totally respect that like attitude
towards like creating art like that nerd
anonymous element but like just today
like something was posted on reddit of
like tool that the band playing one of
the really early shows and it's just
them on stage and the tiny bar without
any shirts on but the thing is was that
was like one of the first shows but then
very quickly after that they pivoted to
the whole like mysterious band thing
without you know going almost like a
decade without posting like photos and
having like the stage really like
ominous and hard to tell who they are
I would imagine four bands starting out
it's kind of like really really hard to
stay consistent with that vibe though
it's like if you know we argue you
already have to be kind of famous yeah
this is a good example we all know they
just have masks and makeup yeah yeah man
got kind of screwed over because the
initial backing band well let's just say
they are all hired studio musicians but
then they obviously studio musicians are
usually really good musicians they all
brought their flair to it and then they
okay you know this bands blowing up and
we're all wearing masks and no one
really knows who we are and you know hey
mr. frontman iord you're kind of the
frontman it would be cool if we could
get some this recognition he's like
mm-hmm
no this is the job you wear masks and
they're like okay we're going to see you
where did this happen the band ghosts
then he's like it's cool I'm still a
very good songwriter and then he
proceeded to continue I make two more
albums they're all pretty solid so you
know is what it is so I guess the
Gorillaz is just two guys two guys and I
guess that's like I think when they play
a live like they they hire a band I
don't know if they're part yeah they
might might not be part of it but
there's a lot of sounds going on a
vicious to you guys
I really the grille is like just former
members from like blur yeah maybe yeah
let's see his band blur yeah Algrim
departed from his this distinct Britpop
band blur such hits as whoo-hoo whoo -
whoohoo and song number two well those
are the same song aren't they oh yeah
you're right he's like I'm not feeling
it anybody could be under those helmets
yeah they've had their pictures taken
here in there though yeah really also
committed to like that's their face and
then every else like I'm gonna copy that
and then you have deadmau5 and yeah yeah
and then all the other ones that we
forgot yeah I feel like being electronic
artists eastes it's like 80% your
branding and like 20% your music a
couple good hits here and there yeah
they still got a hit but like I mean
this club bangers but Allmusic seems
like I mean you really just need a good
engineer so that way you don't murder
people so yours with your synthesizers I
mean we're getting to the point now
there's so much music written that like
it's not really anything that like
stands out unless it has like a new
sound which is hard to do right now like
you could not
you could definitely train an AI just
put out like decent electronic music at
this point it wouldn't be like it
wouldn't invent anything new it's all I
could give you a sound like wow I've
would be like skrillex drop in the first
dubstep song it would be just your
middle-of-the-road EDM but man you can
put out just hours and hours in generic
yeah I found some I found some AI
generated rock music you guys ready for
this boy they're computer speakers into
your microphone
it's gonna be some janky [ __ ] hold on
hold on we got an ad somebody's getting
their 1000 e I mean humans are superior
clearly we solved it here in case you
were wondering whether or not AI or
humans were superior humans still have
it I couldn't get him some pretty gnarly
YouTube ads lately like one today was
just like hey do you shave your balls
[Laughter]
that's like you really appeal into my
demographic bro telling you anybody that
showers with that soap
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] but for real the
soaps full of chemicals and there's no
but if you're using a two-in-one shampoo
you're [ __ ] gay it's like okay yeah
it's like I know it's like that close to
them saying that we should make a
vignette video where it's just it's just
outrageous advertisements every 15
seconds oh my goodness I mean that's by
the way that is you
- video idea right there which is every
like dude ad on YouTube yeah he's a free
idea free idea for everybody maybe will
be it - everything mm-hmm what else is
going on around here guys what else you
been working on when you working on the
edit for you monster that's coming on
nicely there's a so Willy Wonka radar I
think is going to drop the same day as
this podcast same day tomorrow now if
you're watching this ya chances are
through someone who listens to slash
watches the podcast you're also one who
watches the videos on our channels if
you aren't you can head on over to cord
or a crew to watch the robust conquer of
a video or talks about us making it and
shows all the reactions or an over the
corridor and just watch the video itself
without the reactions but at the end of
the corridor video you'll see a little
teaser for three upcoming corridor
videos and that's pretty cool gets me
amp you can see some Sam stuff you can
see something you monster you can see
smoke tacticool three loads as well I
haven't even seen this teaser yet well
as of this podcast I haven't seen it but
just you saying that gets me pretty
amped up in four videos tomorrow are we
really
yeah yep we're doing Willy Wonka rated R
on corridor the making Willy Wonka rated
R on corridor crew doing some gameplay
on node and then this podcast nice you
know psych for that TTT episode of node
yeah yeah yep so that's also live right
now - that's future Jake talking to what
you're doing hanging out here with us
you should go watch those videos right
now I want you to be listening dear
member of the audience Jake if you
remember the Willy Wonka edit yet I saw
it before I gave Nick some notes but I
haven't seen it since he did what I
can't see what he did with those notes
well
it's hilarious he's saying it is very
different from where you last saw Jake
in a very good way it it it transformed
from something that was like rum and
mediocre let's be totally honest into
something that's incredible like I what
was not good what was the difference he
added a whole team which was amazing
like he had you've seen all stated a
scene that fit perfectly well well like
the knife scene yeah yeah he like
brought his dad
so there's custom shots that he filmed
for it which are perfect and they like
baby match flawlessly multiple viewers
in our little session didn't know that
they weren't from the movie oh I'm one
of them I'm one of them I was like I
don't really remember this on top of all
that he picked up he cleaned up the
entire piece
and managed to find completely new takes
of Willy Wonka saying some of the
creepiest stuff that you you don't even
like it's like stuff that I'm watching
and I'm like watching him say it I'm
like that's in the movie like like in
what are these shots it's incredible
not to mention the actual like effects
on the top of all that the scenes are
just completely insane like and I say
insane a lot but it's it's literally
insane like this is crazy stuff guest
appearances from from Peter France as
well on the effects and in Hubert right
yeah yeah if Peter is the Prince of
blender then Ian is the king yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah like truly I feel like I feel
like Ian is probably the the most
versatile blender artists I've ever met
and my Peter
he's one of the most versatile talented
3d artists I know yeah I've seen a lot
of stuff from a lot
people but ian is able to create like
worlds and scenes and stuff that is at
this like crazy level that tons of
people like just spend their whole lives
trying to get good at like one of the
things he's good at so yeah yeah yeah I
mean that thing he put out in that like
kind of technology world with the girl
man elevator I mean it just it looks
like some shade of a Tripoli movie yeah
yeah he he lives a while the life there
we went up to visit him at one time I've
been up in Washington and he's just he's
just living in the woods
no compound making life in weird renders
with with his little sad so over there
and just living it man
I think I'm and like I always like think
about is the really creepy underwater
swimming like the under the Sun because
he has like this whole scenario that
used to be like a cult like a cult
compound it's like a stage you bought a
property that used to be a cult compound
yeah Hiba and then the Church of the
town is a studio as a baptism underneath
the stage there's a stage with a
trapdoor but it doesn't lead to like a
beep like a behind the stage kind of
like area it leads into a like a like a
covered swimming pool almost like it's a
concrete pit it's a tank though it's
actually got as finished like tank yeah
well you when you drop down from this
trapdoor you fall into like like a
concrete pool instant baptism it's just
it's just it's a yeah man well I can't
wait to see it I'll be watching it with
my bare with these very eyes right now
when you're listening to this hmm that's
cool neat neato neato torpedo man what's
uh what's mega steak man doing
the discord well I he he is doing
similar things to what I'm doing in a
real uh so he's been working on doing
some like real-time character stuff and
we've been just kind of trading
information I guess as far as like what
we're doing he's got a whole different
set up but I might have him try and like
come in to help like create the
character models actually cuz I'm using
a method where I photoscan us and then
do a bunch of manual work and he's using
uh some really cool software that is
able to take images of people's faces
and build much cleaner much more
versatile models that you can animate
based off of them and so that the
trade-off there is you get more
flexibility and a little more
expressiveness with like his method but
my method is like well it's a photo scan
of a face so it's like like in most on a
lot of angles it looks a lot more
realistic instead of like looking like a
video game character so to speak so but
yeah that's what that's what we've been
messing with lately did we did we for
people that don't know who he is
he's an artist that what we met through
Mike Deva right yeah yeah he's out and
he's in Vancouver I think or something
like that is he thought it was in
Germany oh no that's he moved to
Vancouver no that's another guy that's
Kelvin oh yeah you're right yep here's
absolutely right you're absolutely right
Sam yeah but we'll see yeah I don't know
I I have a little more work to do before
like doing that but there's definitely a
fork in the road coming up here because
I don't want to like make one and then
like maybe have it does well or
something and we're making another I'm
like let's just like completely create a
new method for this like to just make
sure it has a solid foundation when we
start yes it's not you're not building
everything from the ground up every time
yeah well actually one thing what that
one thing that is really kind of
interesting to talk about so in this
idea that we're doing here since it's
like it's
it's a it's a parody of the VFX artists
reacting where it's video game
characters reacting to their to reacting
to videogames but it's a world where
these characters are working
professionals in the video game industry
but in the fictional way if there's a
wreck it Ralph version of like the
effects artists react well yeah
that's basically what you have with the
video gamers react yeah are you
interesting about the humor though which
I wouldn't mind talking about first in a
second here yeah but but right now as
I'm going through the edit here
basically I'm picking out moments that
we're gonna create custom behind the
scenes for basically where I'm gonna
take game character models of the games
were talking about and our character
models that are talking about it and can
basically create these like many
fictional behind the scenes vignettes
that show our characters like working in
that and there's a whole bunch of it
they're all like really weird moments
that are like they're bizarre they're
they're absolutely bizarre and kind of
right now it's kind of like one of the
biggest sources of like the comedy of
the piece we see that it's really cool
what was that was that like really old
BTS that they spent all that money on
with Jackie was a Jackie Chan Jackie
Chan stunt master game man the tricky
thing about like reacting was that like
we have to like make jokes about what to
make jokes like we're in this world we
still have to reference like pop culture
like a good example like the Avengers
game that's coming out like the game is
these really fancy graphics it's like
they put a lot of attention into it but
obviously like none of the characters
look like the characters from the movies
they couldn't afford the likeness yeah
they just basic but the Avengers game
could license the property and the
characters not bad but but the actors
contracts for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe didn't apply to the game so
like oh yeah like the generic
looking dude yeah so the whole joke of
this like I'm that segment is we're
talking about like now you wouldn't
believe like these faces are
recognizable to every household in
America like the amount of money they
would have to spend like to get these
guys there
it's crazy let's take a look at the
star-studded cast and it cuts the image
and it's like you know who are these
people
it's like here we have Otto Kahn from
Metal Gear Solid
we have Lucas from Smash Brothers in
earthbound we have d-pad woman number
two from the since she's been in the
games like The Witcher
she's been like these are the industry
these are the industry's hardest-working
actress they're all like super famous
likenesses of pre-existing game world
but of course there's a satire you know
a little deep on the whole in fact like
you know these people look like anybody
you know Jensen is Tony Stark
this time with the metal on the outside
of his body mini-boss oh one level one
yeah wait till you see who booked up for
Thor yeah
Luthor is is a secret and that's and the
character that plays Thor is gonna be
one of those scenes where I'm gonna be
creating a our own custom behind the
scenes that shows you how a certain
video game character was able to
transform into one of the most unlikely
characters one of the most unlikely
transformations exactly who knows man
this might be the next like video series
that we do react boys right the whole
time man here we are ten years later
yeah I mean Sam really cool I guess how
long or what like what's the goal of how
long like it would take to produce one
of these episodes well this first one
here is kind of like a hey let's make it
in a timely manner but it's all the way
there's still a lot of question marks
going on so like I mean feasibly though
like after the process gets turned out
like I could see you
I don't know like maybe like you could
really pump one out in two weeks if you
really wanted to the main thing though
is that like you you you still to write
these ones a little bit you know like
they're not pure just like off the top
reactions like you do have to like write
jokes for them because if you're not
actually reacting this yeah it's got to
make sense it's it's a lot a lot of it
is fiction so but like but the big
overall goal is like at least streamline
this process so that it's not what it's
not gonna take longer to do this than to
go out into regular video with like
live-action in a real environment and
and just have have it as like an option
yeah it might be a fun just series to
test and just you know it doesn't need
to stop us from doing anything else but
it's always nice to have those yeah
people enjoy that that we can produce
with a little bit more regularity than
some of our other stuff yeah definitely
alright so do you guys want to talk
about what's what's what's going on with
our studio over the next few weeks or
with coming back in and with the
possible additional space and all that
stuff for my intro home yeah okay well
let's see it's when this comes out smart
its April 24th so what the idea is start
getting together next week to start
filming some things here and there is it
not yes so my arms are disappearing just
getting here it is right that was visual
effects ladies and gentlemen okay yeah
so you know we've been here in
quarantine like a month now working from
home which has actually been nice
silver lining to all this but um you
know the whole thing like with working
from home is that you don't get to hang
out with your buddies and like film
videos and that's become a little tricky
here so like we did a VFX artists react
last the week before last week yeah
where we all set decently far apart and
use a zoom lens to put us close together
and you know we're going to record some
more that but also just being able like
talk to and edit with somebody or film a
segment with somebody those are the
things that like you start doing so
we're trying to figure out like how do
we strategize this and you know for one
like pole team's been really responsible
with social social isolation involved in
at home more not interacting with large
groups of other people so the way at
least the way I see it is if you take
the necessary precautions and we know
where our face masks and wash our hands
we keep our distance you should be able
to get together in groups of two or
three to film something or you know
other stuff that you know involves
having a camera and pointing it at
somebody else and not necessarily being
close to each other I'm starting to kick
that off and little by little getting
back into being able to film some things
and produce some things but you know
we've we've come up with ideas like
Sam's video games reacting where we
don't necessarily have to have a big
crew all in one spot you know it can
just be a couple dudes if even that like
getting together but well will trickle
into that a little bit a little starting
kind with next week and there's there's
a study that the I think it was either
Yale or Harvard or like I know USC did
one where they just took a random
sampling of people in Los Angeles and
found out they're like 4% 4.1 percent of
people have already had the virus I wish
would put the actual numbers that's
anyway yeah yeah I mean maybe it's you
know you have antibodies for something
else and it's a false positive on the
test but if it's not which you know if
they've had multiple connect groups kind
of go do this so it's probably
relatively accurate you know it puts the
total cases in the LA at between 220 to
400,000 which means in our group in
corridor it means that there's a 50/50
chance that one person in the group has
had the virus already go yeah but more
importantly I think it shows you that
you know there's the vast majority
people are ace
dramatic or just show minor symptoms and
obviously for some people it's very
deadly just like you know the flu or
anything else can be obviously the
biggest risk here is that it spreads
like wildfire it's much it's more
contagious and then you know everybody
gets it immense from the hospitals and
they get overrun like that'll still
happen if people aren't careful but in a
way I don't know maybe it means the
disease is just a little less scarier
it's not like hey okay catch it just
keep that everybody gets the [ __ ] kicked
out of them it's like okay it's it's
like the flu it still mess you up but
it's more so about just keeping it from
burning through the population too fast
and then you know it's still unfresh
disease that will still killed new
people and you don't want people to die
anyways
where am I going with all this is that
you know a little bit little we're gonna
start getting back and do like the
studio and filming things together we're
gonna try to figure out a way to do it
safely
but let's film some node stuff to
live-action stuff dude social distancing
tag yes like we've had PVC PVC pipe so
it's like tennis balls at the end let's
do that let's do that next week yeah you
know maybe it's time to also share the
good news through our listening audience
that uh ivy and I put an offer in on a
house and it was accepted and after
living in Hunter Street in the Hunter
Street building for 11 years we will be
moving out and that will be the latter
we will be the last ones living in
studio three so technically started in
studio 6 but we were only there for six
weeks and they moved in the studio three
and that was back in 2009 February of
2009 and we've been studio three ever
since then like our lives have totally
transformed being in the studio and in
two weeks ivy and I will be gone and
that would be that and then what happens
with that studio it's a new spot hanging
out of the studio in total yep Cora
digitally gets to double its floorplan
here and expand into the old corridor
digital studios see you free I'll see
it's the old corridor so happens that
it's happening and Nico your commute
time suddenly jumps out oh man three and
I was in percent having to commute
no no sorry thirty thousand percent I
remember yeah I used to just be able to
walk down the stairs to get the quarter
and now I have to drive my car for 11
years
why no just think I'm like all the hours
I've had like the extra lives I've lived
thanks for not having to commute oh I
know many lives many lives I'm actually
looking forward to having a bit of a
commute I needed like I'm starting to
realize that I need like the 20 to 30
minutes both to and from work to think
about like what we're going to do for
the day and you know where I can be
effective uh I don't really have a boss
you know I just need to like show up and
like figure out the right thing to do or
you know is Jake and Sam can yell at me
but you know I wasn't like it's so you
kind of figure it out your own way just
you don't just sit there until a manager
tells you what to do and then likewise
you know sometimes things get stressful
and like sometimes I have to be like a
hard-ass about something to get done or
like I'm getting frustrated or something
and like wouldn't works done if I just
go home like it's a chance to like
decompress in switch gears so I can feel
like I'm actually my commute the way in
it's like getting ready for the day
catching up on music but you know kind
of just getting the mine ready and then
driving home it's also time to like yeah
it's frustrating when there's traffic
and you don't want to view that long hey
you get in let's go get it hey Gideon
you see hi Gideon anybody I love your
little Mohawk thing again big man he's
kind of blown away with all these all
these screens see it was like I was a
man you heard that earlier yeah is that
[Laughter]
[Music]
so that happened fast though man I mean
here I guess
dinosaur you're looking for houses all
of a sudden that one and now well it's
both fast and slow like I hear I just
want to listen to me tell a story I'm
looking for houses a little bit tell the
tale all right cool
so ivy and I actually started looking at
houses like like four years ago
yeah and we spent like about two or
three months doing it and then just
backed off of it one you know Sam and
Sarah we're still living in studio three
with me an IV so rent was actually super
cheap you know there's big split four
ways at that point and we have a lot of
space here and the commute was really
nice the street was quiet so it kind of
came down to like we didn't really like
we're gonna gain much by trying to get a
house just aside from a lot of debt
doing it and then um you know time
passed Sam and Sarah got married first
and had a kid first and thankfully Sam
Sarah gracious enough to get out of
before the baby was born so that we
didn't have to wake up five times a
night to share in the baby experience
[Laughter]
but there's just ivy and I here for a
little bit and I actually really liked
the idea of being in just a downtown
loft like a true this is a true life
that we have here it's not like you know
some fancy remodeled place like this is
an old office that's wide open and it's
got high ceilings you know it's loft and
yeah you know lived that life for a
little bit so so we did you know did
that for about two years
and then the street got more more busy
my car got broken into
freakin we'd grow up down the street
putting these fans are sold out in the
room actually there's that much demand
for weed what do you know it's cheap and
easy I guess at this point to be fair
those fans in fact they are so loud and
sober Frank I think it actually put the
wrong voltage into them so they're
spending like way fast and they should
be they have all since burnt out
yeah there's one day where there's going
and I was annoying well they also you
know smiled on the inside knowing that
the end was coming to an end
[Laughter]
yeah
then shoot any bb's into it I'm shooting
babies in throwing bolts into them
didn't like put any sand bearings yeah
not me
I'm doing that but uh and that sound
sarcastic I'm being serious I didn't
yeah but so I did I started looking for
for a house you know basically back in
January and okay you know this is city
there's houses yeah I'll be a little
competitive like it was really
competitive like we were not ready for
how competitive like it was like it's
basically any house it's good there's
about 20 other people that are trying to
buy it at the same time and to win it it
doesn't just mean putting in the biggest
price and I'll tell you about how they
screw you over in that process it's also
about like so this is strategy that we
learned as as it went on and it's how
you play dirty when you try to buy a
house so first things first you put in a
really really really high bid higher
than anybody else well first you put in
a high bid and then you ideally get
countered they come back and say okay
your bid is good but this is the new
price to be very often though these days
in LA they don't say that they just come
back and say cool nice thinks the offer
come back counter us now with your best
and final so they don't tell you if you
had the best offer they just say you
need to come back to us with your best
and final which means if you want the
house pick a number we're not gonna tell
you we're just pick a number that's
higher than the number you gave us
that's the highest you would ever
possibly go
your best possible number and then we'll
tell you if you get it so you're sitting
there like wondering like did I was I
already the highest bidder and I just
bidding against myself at this all I
know it's such a [ __ ] move it's
frustrating as all hell but that's what
everybody does and so because of that
all the buyers now have a game that they
play where they come back and they go
okay here's my best and final and then
they blow everybody else out of the
water and come in with a way higher
pricing I'm talking like a hundred
thousand dollars higher than like
everybody else just like really shooting
out there it's crazy the whole idea is
to shut everybody else out of the
process then in the
and then once you're in the deal then
you do the inspections and you'll have
stuff you come back and say well the
pipe was blocked I know it could get
maintained but I want to replace the
whole thing so at $7,000 so just give me
a credit for that you know you have this
like one scenario the drain in the
kitchen you could just fix it for a
hundred bucks but I want the whole thing
your place give me a ten thousand dollar
credit for that like then you go through
and you come back for the list of
credits to knock like a hundred grand
off the price and now of course they're
already like in the deal with you the
escrow is already happening so they
don't really want to back out and
basically you come in with a side price
to kick everybody else out of the
process so it's just you and then you
bargain hard and bring the price back
down to what you actually want to pay
for the house and yeah that's funny yeah
it's super annoying like we would watch
houses that we were into like go into
you know pending or something that in
red fenders illo and drop out like three
weeks later because clearly like
everybody was doing that all over the
place and of course the sellers are like
whoa I thought we'd get the number you
offered I mean theoretically - it's like
you can put in those high bids on a
house go into escrow have inspections
done it and then say actually like this
door is kind of squeaky and but it makes
me suspicious of all the other doors so
I don't want to replace the door so I'm
gonna back out you know it's like you
can you can extrapolate a tiny little
thing into a reason worth backing out if
the seller isn't willing to like
actually you know look at your itemized
chart and negotiate back down yeah yeah
I didn't I think we didn't have to use
that method I mean I moved here like
three years ago he was still pretty
crazy then but what you're describing
Mikko sounds yeah the thing is like we
were also we're aiming for Eagle Rock
which is like an island park and that
kind of stuff which is like one of the
last like neighborhood type places
that's close to LA still like there's
there's neighborhoods around LA but like
in terms of neighborhoods it's like 20
minutes away from LA that like that
reminds me of Stillwater Minnesota which
is where I'm from where like you can
literally walk down the street for a
cafe or like go around the corner to a
park like Eagle rocks in those places
like there's you know space between the
houses there's yards and sidewalks with
trees and you know once again you're
literally 20 minutes away from
one of the biggest metropolitan centers
in America if not the world you know
it's like it's anyhow there's being
scrutinized by so many people um and you
know being fought over but what ended up
happening is so we affect we end up
seeing a house in Eagle Rock that was
small but it had a really nice yard
that's one of the things I really value
this I wanted a really nice yard um just
some spot for Milo and my daughter to be
able to run around in and you know the
weather in LA is so nice that if your
yard is nice and it connects the house
it's basically another room at this
point it's always just room temperature
outside in LA you know so if the house
small you know the yard is nice and who
cares you got a great yard and you sing
out there so you know find this really
tiny but nice house in Eagle Rock and it
had happened it happened to go on the
market in the middle of all the
quarantine and I mean I already had a
downpayment saved like we're all set we
even pre-approved for the loans and
stuff before everything hit the fan so
we're in a good position to continue
looking for houses when suddenly the
demand for house has dropped it's not
the prices for houses didn't necessarily
drop but just the competition but you
know that 25 people put like you know
trying to bargain for a house and get it
like all that disappeared so like you
know those cutthroat Hollywood manager
is trying to buy a house like skis
nobody else has a game they're all
locked in their condos now back in
Hollywood so I guess I finally have a
chance to you know find some houses um
so when you found this house in Eagle
Rock and you put in an offer but right
as we were doing that I saw a house
pop-up in Glendale and it had twice the
square footage and a bigger backyard
there's only four minutes further of a
drive so you know not that much further
and like van that's a really nice house
it's kind of making me have second
thoughts one's Eagle Rock house but
whatever let's do it and then the Eagle
Rock house lost a bit again that was our
fifth house we had put an offer in on by
the way because we had bid on five
houses up to that point as I may be that
Glendale house is available let's go
check it out
and then oh no somebody put an offer on
that house it's off the market like damn
well time for round six let's new you're
getting pretty you know burnt out by
this point looking for houses but our
realtor ends up calling them up and
they're like hey you know we might be
actually backing out of escrow with our
buyer they're kind of being [ __ ] they
didn't say that they're kind of they're
basically like the
the deals not working out and it sounds
like what happened is the strategy to
explain to you have people coming in hi
and then like aggressively bidding down
they were trying to pull that on these
people in Glendale and the people in
Glendale were just like yeah we're good
we don't really really like it was their
home it's not a flip thing it's not an
investment property like it's just a
nice house they took care of it's from
1917 it's just like you know nothing's
brand new in it it's just all been
well-maintained because her family's
actually lived there for 20 years and
took took good care of it it's really
you know we're not interesting with
stuff and also the owners or the sellers
like we're not gonna play that game hey
maybe we'll just wait until all those
quarantine stuff is over so we reach out
like hey we actually like your place
would you by chance wanna show it to us
I know it's you're not like actively
doing that right now but would you just
want to show it to us so we show up we
have our baby and she's super cute or
you know we get to meet them turns out
the owners are also the you know the
listing agents and they think we're cool
they like the baby they like the fact
that we're you know it's the family
looking for a house and we put in an
offer and we put in for just you know
just a little bit a tasteful amount over
the asking price just like you know show
some respect but not you know not a ton
yeah and they're like okay we'll take it
and so he didn't have to deal with any
of the competition we didn't have to
deal with any counter is there's no
bidding wars there's no best and final
they just say here's our price it's
close to what you're asking for with a
little bit on top and they're like let's
do it and that happened like four days
ago so now we have to move out of unit 3
and be in the house by the 13th of May
yeah it's such a hurry up and wait
process it's really funny yeah it's like
yeah
it's a huge weight off our shoulders
though it's like after after the grind
of months and months and like one thing
when your baby is like just a human grub
and I can't do anything but like once
they start wanting to like move around
you kind of like like boy I can't take
you outside it's just literally a street
filled with please like there's no yard
for you to play in like on hikes and
like I sit in the grass and she look at
the grass back
oh my god it's like oh I feel bad this
should be like boring to you by now yeah
yeah so good ngratulations thank you
thank you I'm psyched and the we are you
know a kiss at the end of a we are kind
of getting a deal I mean it's not you
know not saving a ton of money but like
compared to houses that were going for
that price in Eagle Rock and Glassell
Park and Highland Park like it's it's a
step up so it's just we got to avoid the
whole bidding up process which basically
kept the price and rising 10% mm-hmm
yeah Wow I can't believe it's been
interesting to see what the markets like
in in a few months here because who
knows how many buyers there gonna be and
how many they're not going to be I know
it's pretty insane here though and
that's just I mean that's just an
example
one person's example of what it's been
like for people trying to get homes and
get property here
yeah it'll actually what led to it being
so insane recently was the fact that in
2019 everybody was talking about the
recession remember that like it was like
oh we're gonna hit a recession at some
point here were expecting a global
recession there's gonna be recession and
then we're seeing that through 2019 and
then like around comes like December and
then like just a stock market starts
going up there was like even faster it's
like that's kind of weird and then
January hits it's going up even faster
and it's even faster I'm like alright no
recession we're good
and then all the people in 2019 that
were going to buy a house or waiting to
say that it's going to be recession
we're like screw it it's time to buy
houses so at the beginning of 2020
had not just the regular demand people
lined by houses but all the people in
2019 that held off started wanting to
buy houses too so they demand like
doubled briefly and that's when we
happen to get into it too I was tone are
Lee and then you know coronavirus
happened and that put a damper on all
that but dude once that opens once that
lid comes off and people get to start
doing this again this summer like it's
gonna be nuts I'm glad I'm out of the
game now yeah yeah I mean we'll see I
mean like oh like on that note on the
recession there was additional
4.4 million unemployment signups last
week making the five week total
since the quarantines began twenty six
point four million which is more than
all of the jobs that have been gained
since the Great Recession Wow yeah so I
don't know is that a switch is it as
much of a switch that you can flip on
and off as as people have been saying
there's nothing going to be an impacts
you know it's gonna take a little bit
time to recover from it but it is
something where if people can start
returning to their jobs like it'll but
there's no there's no doubt that
business after business is going under
right now yeah even with even with the
care Zach and the payroll protection
program and the frickin you know even
with all that stuff like you know
there's just there's certain markets and
certain businesses that are just gonna
be hit too hard that are already closed
or gonna close soon and those jobs
aren't coming back my friend yeah true
you just grow just like a plant you know
slowly we just trimmed it now we're
about to chop off a major limb do you
think you look rollback yeah your nose
yeah yeah I don't yeah that's the
unexpected thing I mean I think we
should honestly I'll just cross our
fingers and hope that there's not like
an earthquake or something that's like
normally bad you know what I mean like
that happens yeah the next like two or
three months because that would like
that would actually screw things up I
mean yeah yeah it might force people out
of we might force people to start doing
stuff again though too at the same time
I don't know thanks
crazy alright guys well anything else
anyone else buying a house these days
Christian do my best to say that I'm not
working on buying the house yet be nice
future but I don't know we just moved
into our apartment so nice yeah no we're
happy here it's it's probably the best
place I've lived in LA so far other than
the house that we lived in that was a
fun house man awesome house yeah yeah
Jordans made that house real nice over
there yeah well our our whole
refurbishing helped when we repainted
and redid the floor alright guys well
thanks for joining the podcast once
again and till next week
till next time this is our eighth what
are you first episode Wow I really enjoy
these podcasts are a lot of fun
especially like since I don't get a lot
of social interaction right now instead
of my wife and my baby
yeah chance to hang out with my Bros for
a minute it is it's really doing that's
why that's why they're always coming out
at odd hours but that's what we do them
like this because they're more fun that
way
all right guys yep I'll see you guys
later thanks for joining the quarter
cast podcast later guys see ya